ja wir haben uns jetzt hier im central
park mit petrina engel getroffen und sie
ist bloggerin und autorin aus
deutschland wohnt aber in new york
petrina erst mal warum wir uns in new
york wegen york das alles ich habe
nirgendwo mehr geschichten gefunden als
in dieser stadt und gleich vom
geschichtenerzählen lebe war das
irgendwie logischer schritt hin zu tun
wann bist du nach new york gezogen 2010
bin ich umgezogen und davor hatte ich so
eine kleine phase wo ich hin und her
gependelt bin und dachte dass wir eine
gute idee war es aber nicht was magst du
an new york ich mag die stimmung hier
ich mag das licht von new york total
gerne ich mag dass die sonne so viel
scheint ich mag das new yorker insel ist
oder aus ganz vielen inseln besteht und
das am meer liegt ich mag das wasser ja
ganz viele andere sachen wahrscheinlich
auch noch
wir drehen damit machen wir ein programm
zum deutschland viele amerikaner gucken
dass und wir haben auch immer dieses
deutsch amerikanische verhältnis war
auch immer thema bei uns in deutschland
hatten wir komischerweise auch viele
negative antworten über amerika aber
gleichzeitig ist fasziniert amerika ja
auch die deutschen wie wie siehst du das
wie sehen die deutschen auf amerika ich
erlebe es hier auch dass menschen hier
mit vielen vorurteilen hinkommen dass
sie halt also speziell bei new york dann
denken das ist das wäre ja viel zu viel
oder wie kannst du denn da leben so eine
große stadt und dann gibt es das andere
extrem die halt
übermäßig begeistert die oder mit sehr
vielen träumen hier hinkommen und und
halt denken ja dieses wenn du es hier
schaffen kannst dann kannst es überall
schaffen ich glaube das stimmt aber
dafür musste auch hart arbeiten also ich
sehe die die vorurteile in beiden seiten
und ich sehe halt irrsinnig viele
klischees einer fastfood überall mit dem
auto hinfahren autofahren zum beispiel
stimmt in new york schon mal gar nicht
mehr als die hälfte der new yorker
besitzt kein auto
aber ich glaube dass das letzten endes
genauso ist wie umgekehrt guck dir an
wie deutsche touristen im ausland
gesehen werden wie denn keine ahnung
haben die nicht alle lederhosen an
trinken bier fahren alle bmw oder
mercedes oder audi und gucken fußball
und können nicht tanzen und haben kein
humor also so weit ist gilt stimmt also
ich glaube es gibt bestimmt amerikaner
die einem klischee bild entsprechen es
gibt genauso gut sicherlich deutsche die
einem klischee welt entsprechen und wenn
also ich sag dir nochmal anderes
beispiel es gibt hier einmal im jahr
eine deutsche parade
die heißt die steuben-parade da fühl ich
mich überhaupt nicht repräsentiert und
ich fühle mich auch sehr hilflos weil
ich auch nicht wüsste was ich da machen
sollte um es anders zu machen
also leute in uniform sind heute in
trachten david marsh musik gespielt oder
schlechter euro techno und ja die
vorrang dafür einen trabi mit
es gibt ganz viel bier und ja das ist
ein rekordwert
wer macht das sind das deutsche die new
york wohnen oder sind das amerikaner die
deutschland mögen und deutsche wurzeln
haben wer feiert sich da beides es gibt
dann es gibt deutsches und als
einwanderer schon sehr sehr sehr lange
in den usa und in new york waren sie
lange zeit zu anfang des jahrhunderts
die größte 1
ums gruppe siehst du auch auf friedhöfen
noch immer irrsinnig viele deutsche
nachnamen auch hier wenn du mit leuten
spricht so oft deutschen nachnamen
das ist weit verbreitet und in dem zuge
gibt es natürlich dann so heimatvereine
oder so was also gruppen die das die
tatsächlich irgendwann trachten wesen
zumindest einmal im jahr
aufrechterhalten als davon aber auch
organisationen mit von deutschen jetzt
in new york die versuchen halten
moderneres bild zu zeigen indem ich mich
aber auch nicht wieder finde das bild
fußball-weltmeister lecker biertrinken
lecker würstchen essen
ich bin vegetarierin also fast alles im
hass fußball
ich hasse fußball nicht aber das ist
nicht so dass wir wieder rausgeworfen
aber ich meine ihr habt ja in
deutschland gerade diese diskussion um
leitkultur gehabt und so wie ich es von
hier beobachtet habe auch nicht wirklich
beantworten können was sie denn jetzt
das deutsche abendland ausmacht insofern
es ist halt gefährlich mit klischees zu
spielen und wenn du dann darüber
nachdenkst was ist deutsch scheint
vielen leuten das halt einzufangen
wir waren immer angefangen wie die
deutschen auch amerika sehen es gibt ja
einen vielfach auch ein negatives bild
was sie sagen die deutschen irgendwie
diese glauben die immer irgendwie so
eine meinung zu den sachen haben zu
wissen
das heißt du mich ich meine gut ich bin
auch deutsche ich weiß nicht ich
vielleicht wollen deutschen ordnen
also ich glaube das hat viel mit
unsicherheiten zu tun zum beispiel als
ich bevor ich umgezogen bin gab es ganz
viele leute die das ganz cool und ganz
toll fanden es gab aber auch welche die
dann so sagten also für mich wäre das ja
nichts also die sich da selber gleich
klar machen mussten so dass
muss ich jetzt gar nicht machen wo ich
dann denke ja ich habe doch gar nicht
gesagt dass du jetzt mit kommen soll
oder so was er muss ja jeder selber
wissen
vielleicht hat es ein bisschen damit zu
tun dass man dann lieber eine meinung
und eine schlechte meinung über etwas
äußert weil man dann ja gar nicht sich
damit auseinandersetzen muss wie man
wirklich dazu steht oder ob man selber
dass es vielleicht auch ganz toll fände
oder oder keine ahnung vielleicht trauen
sich auch manche leute sowas nicht und
fühlen sich dann schlecht und denken
dann ja das ist so mutig und das würde
ich aber nie machen und dann sag ich
doch lieber ich wollte gar nicht also
sie deutschland so ein bisschen
also ich hab das gefühl also von wie ich
das wahrnehmen was die deutschland und
zwiespältige verhältnis zu amerika haben
und ich glaube das hat auch damit zu tun
dass amerika auch immer so ein bisschen
wie der große bruder ist viele viele
sachen aus amerika kommen viel
innovation eigentlich new york ist ja
sag ich mal die stadt zu der man hoch
schaut sozusagen und manche wie sie
selber sagt manche feiern das total ab
stunde übermäßig und manche sind dann
schon wieder so errani das ist wenn das
alle machen wie ich das nicht machen ich
will nicht wie die amerikaner seien also
dass man irgendwie weil amerika so stark
präsent dass in deutschland hat man da
irgendwie eine meinung zu auch wenn es
einen selber gar nicht berührt habe ich
das gefühl das mag sein ja das mag sein
also ich mag auch sein
das dass das so so ankommt als wollte
amerika jetzt irgendwas anderen ländern
irgendwas überstülpen das haben sie
früher mit ihrer außenpolitik unter bush
ja auch nicht aus so gemacht und hat
einen einfachen und verdammt schlechtes
image im ausland ich finde aber das ist
jetzt auch eine weile her
ich nehme es nicht mehr so war das
amerikaner überall hingehen ihre fahne
im boden stecken und sagen unser ihr
macht jetzt alles so wie wir also das
ist ja nicht so aber vielleicht ist das
so eine umgangsweise einfach mit mit
generell mit fremden dingen ihr kriegt
jetzt viele flüchtlinge und denkt jetzt
auf einem einige menschen in deutschland
denken offenbar das heißt dass morgen
überall alles islamisch ist nur weil
irgend etwas fremdes kommt aber ich
glaube nicht dass schon mal irgend einer
von diesen menschen die da kommen gesagt
hat ich komme jetzt hierhin um euch alle
zu ich weiß gar nicht wie das dann heißt
vision ihren oder so engagieren
es ist halt nicht so oder du sitzt am
tisch und irgendjemand ist kein fisch
und alle anderen sag ich es ja auch gar
nicht so viel fisch obwohl niemand
gesagt hat du darfst das auch nicht
machen vielleicht ist es einfach so so
ein phänomen das es auch bestimmt nicht
nur in deutschland gibt
wir haben auch leute angst vorm fremden
nur
new york speziell es ist glaube ich ein
kleines bisschen anders
für trainer da ist ein buch geschrieben
das jetzt diesen monat rauskommt
fettnäpfe der fettnäpfchen führer new
york was können was kann man darin
erwarten
ich erzähle geschichten über new york
und über diese geschichten erst du dich
beim lesen dem was in new york so los
ist oder wie das ist wenn man wirklich
new york erleben will und weil ich nicht
bin schlage ich dann auch noch mal so
ein bogen und geht ein paar tipps für
orte oder veranstaltungen wo man
hingehen kann und das alles erleben kann
also zum beispiel schreibe ich was über
strikt omas oder über leute die
klatschen das in der u bahn sitzen und
warum die das zu tun
ich verrate dass jetzt schon mal dass
ein surfer in new york surfen
new york liegt am meer man vergisst das
schnell müssen insel nicht mehr besteht
aus vielen inseln eigentlich und hat
mehrere strände und einer davon hat ganz
offizielle surfspots zeit nur eine farce
mina was gefällt den nicht an new york
mir gefallen ganz viele sachen nicht in
new york aber nicht unbedingt so dass
ich sagen würde das bewegt mich jetzt
dazu hier wegzugehen oder sonstwas new
york ist einfach eine zumutung
also new york hier leben achteinhalb
millionen menschen mit plus 2 millionen
touristen jedes jahr ich glaube 40 50 60
millionen jedes jahr die stadt ist laut
die hat ein irrsinniges tempo es ist
wahnsinnig teuer hier allein was man an
miete bezahlen muss es gibt krasser
armut hier das für so was finde ich
alles nicht richtig
das finde ich aber auch anderswo nicht
richtig ich sehe aber auch zusammenhänge
dabei zum beispiel was das tempo angeht
wenn sich in new york eine chance ergibt
muss man schnell zugreifen sonst ist sie
einfach weg ich musste erst lernen dass
gehen zu lassen und zu sagen okay es
wird sich aber dann auch wieder was
anderes ergeben und ich habe dadurch
definitiv gelernt schnell entscheidungen
zu treffen
also deswegen mir gefallen sachen nicht
aber ich versuche was daraus zu lernen
oder meinen teil dafür zu tun dass nun
auch besser werden
ich habe auch noch eine frage was ist
dein lieblingssong in new york zu
schreiben war die inspiration findet
ich schreibe aller meistens an meinem
schreibtisch
ich bin nicht so ein mensch der in cafés
geht oder so höchstens wenn ich
interviews abhör nicht gestört werden
möchte im komischerweise für inspiration
das ist eigentlich die ganze stadt also
ich finde so viele geschichten
mir fällt auch viel in der u-bahn ein
zum beispiel wenn ich da weil es einfach
langweilig ist und man nicht viel
anderes machen kann als nachdenken und
ich schaue wahnsinnig gerne aufs wasser
also was wir jetzt hier hinter mir wenn
ich so wählen
wohin gehen dann kann ich gut nachdenken
was sie sagen für ein mensch der nach
new york umziehen will und vielleicht
kommt aus deutschland oder auch aus
kalifornien oder irgendwo nicht in der
nähe von jörg pastoor rat für diese
menschen in new york
stell dich auf wenig platz ein
also
wenn du wenn du deine umzugskartons
packen und dann verkleinert das ganze um
die hälfte
weil du du bist wahrscheinlich nur eine
sehr kleine wohnung oder ein kleines
zimmer haben und du willst es nicht so
voll stellen und es gibt in new york
genug schöne orte wo du hin gehen kannst
du brauchst den krempel wahrscheinlich
nicht wir trainer und zum abschluss
machen nochmal eine kurze fragerunde das
heißt du darfst auf jede frage nur mit
einem satz antworten was sollte man in
new york als tourist auf keinen fall
machen
im weg stehen was sollte man unbedingt
sehen in new york new york von außerhalb
von mainhattan was hast du in new york
noch nie gesehen
wow
ein kamel
was ist das verrückteste was du in new
york gesehen ist das kann ich schlecht
nicht in einem satz beantworten
ich glaube dass sie jeden tag etwas
anders aber ich sag dir jetzt 1 ein
wettrennen zwischen schlepper boden mit
anschließendem spinat wettessen kalt aus
der dose was du dabei ich habe nicht
mitgemacht aber ich okay jetzt mal das
ganze noch umgekehrt stellt vor du hast
einen amerikanischen freund der fed zum
ersten mal nach deutschland wo sollte er
unbedingt hin
nein natürlich in meiner heimat ins
ruhrgebiet nach buchung oder kaputte
industriekultur sehen das haben die hier
ja auch stimmt und was sollte dieser
amerikaner in deutschland unbedingt
gesehen ein ort der keine stadt ist
nämlich ein café so café wo man torte
isst und kaffee trinkt so
deutsche gemütlichkeit erfahren so was
gibt es für mich also es gibt hier
kaffee ist es gibt auch welche die ganz
schön sind aber diese mit dem frisch
sofa und der torten mamsell und die
dicke sahnetorte das ist gibt es hier ja
auch gerne mal so als ja und letzte
frage diese amerikaner der zum ersten
mal auch deutschland sieht nach
deutschland fährt was wird der doch dort
sehen was er noch nie im leben gesehen
hat das reißverschlussprinzip beim
autofahren
was ist das na ja dass du wenn leute von
links und rechts kommen dass man immer
einen von links rein ist und dann einer
von rechts wieder konnten an der nächste
sowie video auf einer autobahnauffahrt
inszeniert irgendwie aber es ist nicht
so klar deutschland weniger kooperativ
vielleicht danke dir für trainer für
dieses interview
wenn ihr auch mal das buch von der
trainer haben möchtet und ihren blog
verfolgen möchten können das die
zuschauer tun
das buch heißt fettnäppchen führer in
new york erscheint im comic verlag und
wenn man fettnäppchen führer new york
sucht bin ich mir ziemlich sicher man
wird das finden
man findet das natürlich auch auf meinem
blog der heißt moment new york also im
moment bindestrich new york punkt.de und
da
da findet sich nun was aufs buch auf die
dazugehörige facebook seite twitter
instagram unterschreibst du jede woche
über neue ja genau ich schreibe so zwei
bis drei beiträge pro woche also wenn
ihr mal von einer deutschen die in new
york wohnt lesen möchtet wie es hier so
ist dabei könnt ihr natürlich auch
deutsch eben dann guckt bei moment - new
york punkt.de und der link ist hier
unten in der beschreibung danke trainer
dankt dir ja das war hier sehr belebt ja
wir sind jetzt 14 wochen hier also new
york erst ein vertrag aber seit fast
vier wochen in amerika wir haben alles
klar
kommt gut überlegt was wir uns anschauen
die tat
natürlich zu wissen
dass das